i always talk about how you have the  power in your life always i know that  you may have your feelings hurt i know  you may be angry or upset or frustrated  i certainly feel those things all the  time in my life but i want you to  understand that no matter what's going  on you always have the power because you  can choose what you think and what you  do next  you may not be able to control the way  that somebody treated you you may not be  able to control uh the number of  promotions that have passed you by you  may not be able to control whether or  not your boss is a jerk face or not to  you  but you can choose how you respond to  these things and that's where your power  is